foreign
ERS in Des Moines Iowa what's up Teresa
hi thank you very much for taking my
call you got it what's up how can we
help hi yes I am a 56 year old female
and I am
single and I've been single since 2003
so I pretty much raised my three
children
went through school became an RN a
registered nurse got my BSN I was a
debt-free wood College then I went back
to get my BSN and graduated or excuse me
my Master's and graduated in
2013 and had 85 000 worth of student
loan debt so
yeah yeah I wish I would have heard
about you guys a long time ago so I feel
like I'm a little bit
um
um behind
um just for the divorce and being a
single mom it was really hard to save I
worked two jobs and being a nurse I mean
it's I did what I could but my question
is right now so last probably 14 months
ago I just said I'm gonna go work I'm
gonna work work
so I worked probably six to seven twelve
hour shifts a week for 45 days in a row
and so all I've been doing is working
for the past year
so I went from 110 to like 250
000. wow
yeah super excited but don't screw with
a single mama with a goal in mind that's
right now we're very strong women that's
right yeah and that's how I've raised my
kids to pretty strong good kids so my
question is is pay the student loans off
and I have a house that is worth like
210 to 220 000. I owe like a hundred
thousand on it
so I'm wondering I've got the student
loans paid now
and so what do I do I have a four
percent which I don't have a 15 I have a
30 year which I know but I have been
paying like 10 000 extra a month pay it
off this year
so just go ahead and pay it off okay
because I've been meeting with my
financial advisor
well I never got but one thing that I
want to step in really quick because I
didn't feel like there was a there was
an either or here so should I what so
what was the other side of this question
wow he feels like since I have four
percent that I should be
um putting more money away in like
mutual funds because I do have a 401k I
have a traditional Roth and I have
a um
a Roth IRA so what so pardon me there
are a lot of numbers and I was trying
hard to pay attention I'm sorry do you
have any debt other than your house
right now
no I have no doubt okay here I just got
out of everything I just worked okay and
so so you are you are working on baby
step six paying off the house that's the
baby step that you're in correct
current mm-hmm okay and so and what your
advisor is is saying pay the minimum on
your house and put as much money as you
can in your Investments because your
house note is at a four percent interest
rate
and your advisor can make more money
right with you putting more money in the
market so of course here's a financial
interest in you putting money in the
market yeah so no you you walk to walk
the baby steps
and then put every other Penny on your
house get that house paid off because
here's what we're looking for we're
solving for freedom
all right we're solving for no other
liabilities do what I have 160
in liquid cash in the bank so that's why
I'm not understanding okay hold on all
right so we're gonna said that I'm
behind no and so okay Teresa I'm sure
your financial advisor is a good dude
but we're gonna stop listening to him he
didn't get a vote anymore you can find a
new advisor so do you believe in that
okay so do you believe in the baby steps
right you've been walking them to the
best of your ability
all right so listen you shouldn't have a
160 000 in cash you should have in your
emergency fund three to six months
whatever that number is if you want six
months six months is good so let's just
walk through this what is six months of
your household expenses what's that
number minus a mortgage actually 30
000 put away for that so you're telling
me you have 160 above and beyond the
thirty thousand
correct are you keeping your mortgage
because it feels snuggly you like it no
no because this is what he's talking
about
John she's got bad advice
excuse me hemorrhoids pay it off pay it
off pay it off while I get John a tube
of Preparation H let's focus on what you
do today what you do terrible advice is
you stop listening to your financial
advisor how much is the house mortgage
what's left on it 100 Grand there's a
hundred on it and it's worth two times
listen listen
I want you to pay a hundred grand today
today
like okay like put her on put her on
I've just put her on hold here's the
deal you need to call your your mortgage
company transfer the money all right
you're free and clear before dinner yes
my gosh all right now you still got 60.
I want your neighbors asking why is
Theresa doing somersaults in the front
yard because you don't know anybody
anything and then you should fire your
financial advisor and go to
ramseysolutions.com and get one of our
trusted Ramsay Pros okay and they will
help you with what to do with the 60
above and beyond the emergency fund
invest that you are debt free your baby
step seven before dinner time and
financial advisors
congratulations you can work a 10 key
it's so fun to push buttons on the
calculator and show somebody well if the
return is this [ __ ] you're talking to a
single mom who's busted her butt for the
last 20 years yeah and you're like you
know what you're behind hold on you're
gonna you're failing give me your money
I'll make it okay for you yeah dude you
know what I'd like to help you get
hemorrhoids listen man right in the
throat right in the Adam's apple boom
I'm not gonna hit anybody I just I'll
take your inside well you don't want
hemorrhoids either it's metaphorical it
is it's a metaphorical listen man for
freedom I don't care what your APR is
you want to be 65 years old and have no
liabilities
that if your job goes away if you're
unable to work if if yes we want a
retirement we're going to build that up
we're going to put 15 in we're going to
put 15 in and the stock market's on sale
great you're gonna have 60 000 to figure
out how to how to put in that thing
but have no payments
have freedom for the first time in 20
years you work too hard
to have a bank telling you what to do
with your life